a avó do pobre não você pode prestar
atenção que a vó do pobre tem a chapa
solta a dentadura do pobre é solta ela
brinca com os dentes minha avó mesmo
estava conversando comigo do nada ela
faz isso aqui ó lava
roupa lava roupa todo
[Música]
dia eles brincam com os dente dele a vó
rica lá do meu amigo perguntando se eu
já tinha assistido todas as temporada de
Game of Thrones Olha eu assisto go assim
sensacional aquele ator que faz um anão
eu acho sensacional aquele cara que ele
cara queer de joelho a série inteira
gravando é um trabalho profissional
assim eu gosto muito daquela sério
entendeu aquele an não acho um charme de
falar a verdade comprei até uma
cadeirinha de bebê para passear com ele
sabe sensacional a velho assistindo
sério eu fiquei Meu deus essa é a
diferença da vó do Rico PR a vó do pobre
a vó do rico já tem Netflix já sabe
mexer num controle